ten dollars a week more doing something
that you don't feel good about compared
to something you'd feel good about yeah
make a change stop thinking that you
can't be more know that you could be
great like if we could change one thing
with our culture I think of great start
maybe not the end all be all but would
would be encouraging people to do the
thing that they love that they feel like
they were put on this earth to do
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
using it so let's start your day off
where I grab your cup of coffee and sip
on today's message try to find your
passion over to you Warren Buffett
[Music]
nights students last week honored 60 of
them from Harvard and South Dakota State
I just tell them try to find your
passion and you know I mean may not find
it the first time but you know don't
sleep walk through life find something
that you really enjoy doing if you can
do it and not you know not everybody is
lucky enough to be able to find that but
it's it ought to be your goal to make
$10 a week more doing something that you
don't feel good about compare doing
something you'd feel good about make the
change bill said something I thought was
really interesting he said the thing you
do obsessively between age 13 and 18
that's the thing you have the most
chance of being world-class at yeah bill
said his one thing was coding what was
your one investment no bill and I his
father many years ago right after we met
had us a group of about 20 right down on
the sheet of paper one word that they
thought accounted for her success and
Bella guy who may only met twice didn't
know what the other one was writing down
we both wrote down the same word which
was focused and he was focused on
software I was focused on investments
and it it gave me a big advantage to
start very young there's no question
about it
I think most people sleepwalk through
life I think is absolutely true I think
most people know that they could be
doing something bigger badder bolder
influential happier more productive more
resourceful I think a lot of people have
that sense they could be playing on a
higher level it's why I start these
videos with I believe you'll have
Michael Jordan level talent I believe
that I think you could be the best in
the world that's something I think you
have that ability to find one thing that
you could be among the best in the world
at and it's why I'm trying to solve what
I think is the world's biggest problem I
don't think MJ's the best basketball
player of all time I think it's an
accountant because he never picked up
the basketball I think you literally
could be the Michael Jordan of something
but you feel stuck doing the thing that
you're doing right now and so if you
have any inkling of awareness that you
should be playing a bigger game here's
what I encourage you to do one it all
starts with your most important core
value you look at Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett they both wrote down focus I
wrote a book called your one-word you
can go through that process you like
find another process if you like but it
starts with what is your most important
core value what are you staying for is a
human being and then you get into what
is the thing that makes me come alive
for Michael Jordan it's playing
basketball for a Warren Buffett is
investing for Bill Gates it's coding
what is the thing that makes you come
alive and if you don't know then that's
okay
like don't freak out don't feel like
just because Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett found it between 13 and 18 that
if you're older than that you missed the
boat all you need to do is explore salsa
dancing is one that came up for me I
didn't dance in my teens I didn't dance
until I was older and now I own a salsa
dancing company the largest one maybe
North America it came because I said yes
I tried I explored
I said yes a salsa dancing I said yes
the snowboarding I said yes to rock
climbing the other toy didn't like salsa
and I stuck with if you don't know what
it is that you want to do then you need
this to start saying yes and trying
everything once I think people way too
quickly lock themselves in on one path
because they feel either forced by
forces around them right their parents
society their friends if you force it
you have to go down that path you feel
like a failure because you tried one
thing and it didn't work out so now
you'll never be that person and you have
to go down
path now that's not the way to look at
it you have to experiment you have to
fail you have to try things you have to
see if you like it you don't just go to
one restaurant and think this is food
and that's the rest of your life gonna
go to the same restaurant forever and
ever and ever and ever and ever you have
a try
you gotta explore you have to say yes
and so this speaks to the problem that
I'm trying to solve I think most people
do sleepwalk through life I think if
that's you don't settle stop settling
for where you are in life right now stop
settling for the life that you have stop
stop thinking that you can't be more
know that you could be great you could
be great you are great you already have
everything you need right here
you don't need anybody's validation
anybody else's resources anybody else's
approval you already have what it takes
to be great
just find your core value believe in it
and then explore to find the thing that
makes you come alive that's it that's
the home run then you're Michael Jordan
it's not easy it's simple but it's not
easy but I guarantee you you don't get
there by sitting on the couch and
watching Netflix complaining about your
life I just want you to win guys you
have Michael Jordan level talent let's
see it come out now I've got a really
special bonus clip for you but I want to
know first question of the day what is
it that do you have that Michael Jordan
level talent in what is it what's your
passion let me feel it put in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot a vinspresso
expresso give me go
pursue what interests you not what
you're good at you're always better off
pursuing the things you like over the
things that you have some kind of
aptitude to are in the end of it at the
end of the day passion for something
gets you much further than some dry
notion of ability here is how I actually
have experienced the world so passions
are created they are not innate it's not
something that's born within you I've
walked people through how I developed my
passion for film before I've walked
people how I developed my passion for
the body and helping people with
nutrition so I won't belabor that point
now but just know that it is something
that you create it starts with an area
of interest you engage with that
interest it either gets more interesting
to you which I'll call a fascination or
doesn't if it doesn't move on to
something else find another area of
interest engage with it and see if it
grows an interest and the easiest way to
understand that is as you engage with
that as you spend more time with it is
it giving you more energy than it takes
so if it gives you more energy and you
feel alive and you look forward to and
you want to do it that's a very good
sign that this is something that's
leading towards a real fascination now
in the book so good they can't ignore
you Cal Newport really differentiates
between the classical view of a passion
which is like I was born with it I'm on
fire and it's just naturally amazing and
what I think is actually a passion which
is the act of gaining mastery takes a
deep fascination and turns it into a
passion but I think like love is a
reciprocal relationship and you're not
actually in love if there's no
reciprocity I don't think you actually
have a passion unless you're gaining
mastery in it and you're able to alter
the world in some way through that
whether it's a musical creation whether
it's becoming an incredible teacher and
you know that you're impacting people's
lives whatever it is your skill set
actually allows you to serve other
people and that emotional resonance of
going wow I worked really hard for this
skill set I am actually good at this
thing and being good at this thing
actually allows me to manifest that in
some way that is tangible in the real
world Michael asks why did you give up
medicine to be a pro photographer to be
clear I never
gave up medicine I hit the ripcord they
eject the launch then whatever I aborted
I dropped out I quit specifically
because I was chasing something that
somebody else wanted for me something
that not just my parents not just my
family but I felt like what society
expected of me I literally remember
asking people like Oh what should I do
when I grow up was your experimenting
and thinking about this as a young
person and like well you're smart you
get good grades you're hard worker you
should be a doctor because that's what
people who are hardworking and smart do
be a doctor or lawyer you make good
money and like literally that was the
societal frame that I was given I'm done
with this water I don't know why I still
hold on to that water and I think that's
horrible
it's catastrophic if we could change one
thing with our culture I think of great
start maybe not the end-all be-all but
what would be encouraging people to do
the thing that they love that they feel
like they were put on this earth to do
that's what I did and and believe me I
don't make it sound like it was easy it
was so hard I spent years and years
doing what other people wanted me to do
and I had to grow a pair and do a lot of
soul-searching in here and figure out
that I figure out what I wanted to do
and then be have the the heart to do
that thing and I feel like I'm a very
confident hard-working person who had a
lot going up you know middle-class
upbringing I can't say that I had this a
child had built with struggle and it was
hard for me to break through the clutter
and do the thing that I was supposed to
do so for those folks who were
disadvantaged came from a single family
home or a single-parent home or God
there's a million challenges I can only
imagine how hard it is so long answer
but it was very hard for me to not
pursue medicine but dear God if I could
change one thing I would help people
find their passion this vault
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details